-Over the past several weeks,
Kanye West has expressed
controversial opinions
about racism in America.
This culminated yesterday
in a visit to TMZ
during which Kanye described
slavery as a choice.
Now, commenting on a black man's
opinions about slavery
is not something
I'm comfortable doing.
-But I am!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is, um...
This is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin.
-Kanye, I'm sure you think
what you're doing right now
is fun.
But your words are being used as
fuel for the alt-right movement.
And my biggest concern
is your words will affect
how black children
see themselves!
You're telling them
that it is their fault
that they are at a disadvantage.
So now I have no choice
but to counteract
all the harm you've done.
-How are you going to do that?
-By speaking directly to
the hearts of young people
using the most powerful art form
known to man.
Rap. Hit it!
[ '90s-style hip-hop beat
plays ]
-Amber!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, Amber, are you even
good at rapping?
-No, I'm not.
[ Audience clapping
rhythmically ]
Whoo!
A-come on, a-come on.
Please stop clapping.
♪ African Americans' history ♪
♪ Should be a great source
of pride ♪
♪ Surviving the atrocity
of slavery to thrive ♪
♪ As part of a society
is something black people ♪
♪ Should all be proud of ♪
Hunh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um, Amber, when is the last
time you heard a rap song?
-1990.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty sure they had rhymes
in 1990.
-Seth, this is for the children!
[ Laughter ]
Uh-huh-hunh!
♪ To imply that slaves had
a choice, minimizing slavery ♪
♪ And undercuts the strength
of the black community ♪
♪ Something that Kanye
used to be a part of ♪
Hunh!
[ Laughter ]
-So...
Amber, these are
very important points.
But I just don't know if
this is the coolest way
to get those points across.
-Too late!
[ Laughter ]
I've already committed!
♪ Kanye's scary comments
are a prime example ♪
♪ Of what happens when
you have no black friends ♪
♪ You can't just repeat what
your rich white friends say ♪
♪ Your music may be fresh, but
your views on race are garbage ♪
Hunh!
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
-Give it up for Amber Ruffin,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]